hello viewers listen we don't want to be
those entertainers who are
self-important enough to make the entire
show about this horrible disaster that
occurred this week as though we're
raising awareness because you already
know what's happened with with the storm
with with Harvey what's been going on in
South Texas but a lot of people out
there have been doing whatever it is
that they can you can give your time you
can give money and here at louder was
crowded were able to give a platform I
can't just write a check for hundreds of
thousands of dollars like Miley Cyrus
none of us here can't we're not there
yet hopefully we will be eventually but
what we do have is a platform and you
guys the listeners and the viewers so
here is what we are going to be doing
this this whole platform louder with
Crowder the next two weeks every single
bug Club sign up in the next two weeks
we're going to give $30 directly to
Harvey relief specifically to the
Houston Food Bank and that's because
they're an organization where a huge
portion of your money actually goes
directly to those in need you can read
up on them they have a great track
record $30 of every single mug clip so
to a lot of credit calm slash mug Club
will be given directly to those in need
and we also own this happen we thought
well we have another sponsor that would
be perfect if they could help help us
here and match it and you know we've
done prepared with Crider calm for a
while Patriots apply is one of our
partners and we've always said listen
we're not doomsday people but I lived
through the ice storm in Montreal my
brother has been in Los Angeles when you
have these earthquakes that is what the
emergency food kit is for and they've
come in really handy as a matter of fact
they are using these at shelters in
Houston so right now doing $30 of every
mug Club sign up to harvey relief and if
you go to prepare with credit com you
buy the emergency food kit it's $99 ship
to your door free that's a 30 day food
supply prepare with credit calm for
every single kit that you guys buy
they're actually going to provide an
entire week's worth of food for those in
Houston so that's mug Club $30 prepared
with Crowder calm and listen if you
really just don't want to line our
pockets we understand it there are other
organizations that do a lot of good work
or if you don't want to buy a food kit
or a mug Club subscription is too
expensive some good organizations are
obviously the Red Cross the Salvation
Army is doing a lot of good work down
there Austin pets alive is a good one
South Texas if you're in Texas blood and
tissue Center or whatever it is that you
can do what they really need right now
is they need
sources they have a lot of volunteers so
then you get support the resources that
means money and they need they need room
they need homes so if you're in the area
and there are people who need homes
open up your homes or if you can't there
are animals that needs home need homes
it can just be fostered until they're
reunited with their owners whatever it
is that you can do this is what we can
do
la doors credit calm flush mug Club $30
for the next two weeks and for the next
two weeks we are so grateful a Patriot
supply preparer with credit com will
match this food kit to those in need and
now on to the regular immature
programming hopefully you expected
nothing more previously on game of
thrones your pledge to serve me as your
queen is very much appreciated Jon Snow
I pledge to serve you as my queen
because you show me something Daenerys
that I have not seen in a long time and
what is that hope and what of you do you
that hope for your own Kingdom I concern
myself not with kingdoms or crowns
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's called the it'z sexism because we
don't have breasts and can't do that
dance you think about it we have so
that's why men are not considered very
good dancers unless we have a female
dance partner we just have fewer tools
great show today we have n CH Pierrot
Dean Cain on the show producing with
movement video studio as always as Jared
who is not K follow him on Twitter at
knock' Jared meatus crowded with your
thoughts your comments your photo shops
I fulfill my legal obligations drawing
conclusions are we good knock day is
confirmed it is confirmed also Gerald
Morgan is on the show aji Morgan Jr how
are you today so I'm doing well sir
what's the one day one of the day is
seven hills Cabernet sounds to me like
you liked me shaking my breasts ben
shapiro by the way a little bit of a
change of pace obviously we're so
grateful this this the harvey relief
will be going on for two weeks didn't
really want to talk a whole bunch about
that didn't really want to get into
politicizing that chris cuomo does a
good enough job for us we'll get into
that but then shapiro and i will
actually some people been asking how do
you know been how long have you known
been so we'll get his thoughts in the
news today but kind of give you a little
bit of a personal timeline so some of it
there is interesting
teaser been put me up for a job on radio
and the audition was so awful on my part
i think he almost got fired just for
recommending me okay other news day well
it was it was like these news in america
like reading them at breaks oh so kind
of like when i subbed in for you there
you go yeah similar only far more
embarrassing yep and much more damaging
to benefit the tumblr did it
tumblr did it enough mmm outrage from
all sides right now this has been
trending lee today over a remake of Lord
of the Flies which because it's 2017
will feature all women that can only go
well Lord of the Flies will feature all
women it's being tentatively titled
and they're dead that's the working
title it's about how will women fare in
a survivalist situation but it's it's
not well no I cannot imagine this is
going to go well some feminists are
praising the film because like with
ghostbusters they're happy we have an
all-female we don't like anything
original
so feminist so let's just take guy
things and appropriate it so some are
actually saying it's going too far a
script was leaked and some people think
it may be a little too much we're in an
act of desperation the gang allegedly
piggies ovaries so it's something
they're little upset about now is this
try making a fire with that is it the
feminist version where they all get
talking conks and it's just a lot of UMS
yeah the other working title is high
school high school I used to work at
Target these these broad they can't
manage the shoe department without
turning into it I can't help it is hard
and our diverse people tell you that as
any woman who's worked with the majority
oh the woman yeah pretty girls on the
island you know when they had you know
bikinis that's very tentative title
girls gone wild yeah if they're
attractive it's girls gone wild right if
they're ugly its box office disaster
yeah exactly
they're stuck between a rock and a fat
feminist place that was on this about
Lord of the Flies
it taught me very early on and I don't
know if any of you have had an
experience like this you can tweet me
tusk writer taught me very orally leave
your comment in the comment section that
I deal with tragedy through humor
because I remember seeing the film and I
was upset for weeks
as a kid when they just spoiler alert
bash Piggy's head in with a rock and
stole his glasses and I was so upset
about it as a kid I remember then we
were reading it in high school in the
class and I knew that it was coming up
that the the portion of the book where
they kill Piggy and I started laughing
hysterically and uncontrollably haha
and it was just and I didn't know why I
love you yeah I always pronounced it
conch has your [ __ ] Theresa mate
this is the hairline I couldn't see
Theresa made you see this headland
Theresa made condemns North Korea in the
strongest terms possible okay so she
said that that freaky little Muppet can
go self upside down with a wire brush
until he develops equal pops and
colorectal because absolute scourge on
society as a pizza that Steven just said
we condemn North Korea in the strongest
terms possible now I'm gonna look like
ya know maybe jump the gun
what do they think they're accomplishing
by using that same term every time
something terrible is described you in
the strongest terms possible really I
can't be the only way see these
headlines like in the strongest terms
possible
it's gotta be real like my dad
instead of instead of spanking me I I am
disappointed and let me let that be
noted in the strongest way possible you
mean you're not gonna beat my ass
strongest way possible
oh speaking of a disappointment to dad
DNC pool boy in chief Chris Cuomo got
into it with Kellyanne Conway he tried
to pivot Houston to climate change
global know it is climate change right
now just just see for yourself first you
berated me for asking the question and
made it sound as if I weren't caring
about the situation I think the cause of
the storm I'm exposing the irony of the
conversation here's video you play
amateur climatologist tonight and I will
play professional helper to those in
need and continue in my job here as
counsel to the president no come back he
just sits there
he just got bitch-slapped it was it was
it was painful to watch
it's painful to watch somebody going to
somebody else's show and embarrass them
and actually I don't know if you a lot
of people missed it
miss this because they just see that the
highlight is over by the context but it
it gets worse for Chris if you look at
his real reaction yeah here's video you
play amateur climatologist tonight and I
will play professional helper to those
in need I think he needs to focus more
perpetually ticaboo he does he always
looks like hey so run to that legend
during the commercial break he's running
in the bathroom it's like clear the path
jared is somebody with experience in
this yeah I just said the day a cement
walk past me at world market this person
this round tubby Asian kid skooby skooby
skooby suicide I would have sworn it was
like Chris Cuomo the head of the
bathroom then he sat down right next to
me on the bench did nothing what
solutions people over I was way
screaming excuse me where was the bench
is right next to me but where were you
out in front of the soar
which is your seat will market Oh Oh
world market was going anyway on say you
live in a very suburban area where there
no Cengiz there was a bench is also
either you were buying methamphetamine
is very very uncomfortable yes of a
story and I still think there needs to
be more context provided okay Japanese
pro wrestler this is actually this is a
big for people who are in pro wrestling
fans but the Japanese pro wrestler has
become the first ever to top the Pro
Wrestling Illustrated 500 list so for
those who aren't necessarily fans of
fake fighting with sweaty steroid in men
let me provide you with some he's known
as the Rainmaker
Kazu chika Okada actually is he's the
first one this is big and he's really
you know he accepted it the award he's
proud to be number one Okada though he
said he'll always live in the shadow his
father a legendary zero so that's
something that it's not too soon it's
never too soon no no and they surprise a
lot of people yes is a big wrestling
publication it's like the Sports
Illustrated recipe for yeah kids I don't
know it's big in Japan wrestling is huge
it's the United States kind of like
baseball United States and Japan it's
just it's this huge subculture there so
it surprised a lot of people in the
United States I'm a wrestling fan it
didn't really come as a surprise to
wrestling fans or those in the Japanese
community after Okada's most recent what
really it's it's become an iconic
victory in the ring
[Applause]
you're a wrestling fan no I was about to
say well I wasn't I was a kid we
exported douchebaggery to Japan and
apparently they love it and recommend
say wrestling is douche bag come on it's
just silly
this played out yet anyway to fit in
David down we going nope never realizing
that laid out because we're the only
ones at the balls to laugh that's true
yeah we felt bad for about three seconds
they're like no this is a pic okay I was
surprised this to the backlash we
probably have received the biggest
backlash over laughing over david dowell
and then telling the truth about bruce
lee well and then the rapper who got
shot who said he couldn't be shot i
think we were ahead he actually wrapped
up bulletproof and was shot dead or in
terrible taste Apple of course yes I'm
songs don't age well but funny yeah yeah
it's true
some songs some films don't age well the
guy who rapped about being bulletproof
getting riddled with bullets that would
be not in the category at all right so a
lot of people have been asking about
this since there's not a whole lot in
the news outside of listen help however
you can with Houston
I wanted to dive into something because
a few people have asked questions about
this and they're there at the forefront
of some news stories right now the
Southern Poverty Law Center for those
who don't know SPLC you probably see it
around quite a bit now why is this
something I wanted to dive into because
YouTube is is really using the Southern
Poverty Law Center they've talked about
their their hate speech guidelines now
when they're combing through not only
YouTube but if you look at Google you
look at some of the third-party unbiased
resources places like Facebook are using
snopes politifact
and you see how far left they lean will
the Southern Poverty Law Center is
situated themselves we're they have a
lot more influence over the things that
you see or read online than I think yeah
you necessarily know so let's let's go
through a history here and get to where
they are today with YouTube so this is
out started in 1971 the Southern Poverty
Law Center was founded by civil rights
lawyers Morris Dees and Joseph Levin jr.
and it was fed as a law firm to fight
poverty to fight racial discrimination
and the death penalty so we're starting
off yeah well here's the thing even if
you don't necessarily
with their politics you can understand
okay a legal defense fund or a firm to
fight against the death penalty I get it
yeah I mean were these guys Catholic by
the way because I know that's a big
Catholic position on the death penalty I
mean I get fight poverty and racial
discrimination but that part is what
certainly not in their in their code of
conduct as it stands today what it is is
you know more of a social justice issue
then in 1981 the Southern Poverty Law
Center began clans watch it was a
project monitor in the KKK okay I'm fine
with it
I mean I don't think it's that hard to
spot a Klansmen anyone is it Robert Byrd
no is he near Robert Byrd that increases
the higher the chances by 99% the same
stats you never mind that yeah never
mind a bedsheet and a horse so they
started with the clans watch but then it
turned into a much much broader hate
watch which is what we know today and
we'll get to that in a little bit
in 1986 the entire staff outside of the
founder left the SPLC and most of them
said it was because the organization was
shifting from fighting against death
penalty from fighting for social justice
sort of landmark cases to simply
targeting conservatives and creating
their right-wing hate watch so that was
1996 any questions no I mean is that
pretty much because we decided that it
was better for them to be able to pull
themselves out of poverty instead of
just be giving free handouts I mean is
that where that kind of comes from with
a Democrat they're kind of going after
conservatives because conservatives are
saying hey we're gonna be a job this is
this is one thing where people have been
saying I was always a Democrat and this
is one thing kind of bothers me I was
always a Democrat until they became so
extreme now this timeline shows you if
you look at the left-wing activism
accusing the right of being racist has
always been one of their there yeah
they're going backing it up by giving
out you know the big social programs
they do shifted leadership did anyone
who's conservative is it hate speaker
you know see their hate watch it doesn't
have anything to do with economics or
death penalty okay 1991 Southern Poverty
Law Center they they launched the
teaching tolerance program to influence
educators and instruct students on
social justice and quote anti-bias
well how about anti social justice
that's somewhere in the list so if we
are an organization founded on biased
ideals get it I'm gonna fight bias it's
like that it's like the gun cabinet with
the power of heart
you are useless Mowgli wannabe words
like a bow and arrow and Avengers
what's-his-name yeah Hawkeye I'm a great
shot it's it's a robot it's robots what
the hell are you gonna do yeah them I've
got I've got uh Valyrian steel probably
another firing everything about Hawkeye
just offends the sensibilities okay
sucks so this is what happen with
southern problem I wanted to give you a
timeline of where they started what
their purpose was law firm fight these
social justice causes and then it came
to alright everyone whose right wing is
horrible and they started creating these
maps and clans watch became hate watch
so that brings us to today the Southern
Poverty Law Center today only serves as
a propaganda wing of the left people
need to understand that
so this hate watch if you go and see it
it looked to discredit any conservatives
by labeling them extremists and putting
them on these watch lists and you can go
see these right now it's better than the
Southern Poverty Law Center I think do
we have do we have the map yet the map
is up now so they went from fighting the
Klan to now fighting hate groups and you
see on this map got mad about Sarah
Palin yes Matt because districts to vote
them out but they're actually putting
targets on these are hate groups and
amongst these people on these maps or
these groups are hate groups like the
Family Research Council Alliance
defending freedom hate speakers dr. ben
Carson yeah because he he said that he
supported traditional marriage because
he talks a lot enough to threaten anyone
yeah planet so this is this they pulled
that back I think in 2015 but they put
all of these groups or people on it's
kind of like care with yours truly I'm a
hate speaker by the way
failed terrorist organization care yeah
come you didn't come at us legally care
I'm okay with that when you said that in
nineteen eighty one when they
transferred it to hate groups that's
when I kind of cringed I was like oh
gosh man that just that just leaves
everything open whoever decides to take
you're just gonna watch it becomes
entirely subject yeah because not only
Ben Carson but people like a Jana here
CL Lee we've written up there she's a
liberal atheist you feminist so why is
she hate speaker because she speaks out
against Islam right someone who was
raised with Islam somebody who's seen
the evil underbelly she's officially
labeled a hate speaker if you look at
the the Southern Poverty so you lay out
their sacred cows and say these are
off-limits Caesar off-limits Islam
feminism
Bruce Lee threatened to kill Christians
all over the planet you're totally well
this this brings them this is it brings
them to their primary purpose and and
this is what's most is concerning it's
to silence free speech so their goal is
to create this this veil of all of these
people are extremists therefore what do
you do it's just like antiphon Nazis
right that's what happens like ant if it
was not just if you think everybody is a
Nazi if you say everyone disagrees to
you does not see someone says well what
if what if I punched them and then you
accidentally punch your own people it is
important to not punch somebody just
because you think they are not see how
about don't punch them period exactly
even if they're not see don't punch them
how about that just don't punch people
because of their points of view so this
is when you when you paint everyone is
extremist and Southern Poverty Law
Center has been doing this for a long
long time I encourage you to go read the
time on it don't take my word for it
like levar burton find some six-year-old
who can vouch for me
so it's it's troubling because youtube
is using them as one of their partners
for i have the term here hate news index
the documenting hate project so yeah
groups like the Southern Poverty Law
Center in Louisville are relied upon as
unbiased resources I'm biased for
YouTube to determine what is and isn't
hate speech now this they're using these
four videos where the same you're not
necessarily a violation like recruiting
for Isis or beheadings but kind of in
that veiled area of hate speech okay so
now we're using the SPLC so it's ben
Carson and I'm really into this so no
marriage we're gonna ban the flag
immediately and here's what so here's
what's so upsetting about this when you
this is a YouTube made them a partner
after the FBI completely dropped them
out they were using the Southern Poverty
Law Center then in 2014 they stopped for
the exact same reasons that have
outlined and not only that it should it
should be noted it's not just
ideological the FBI decided to drop them
because they've actually been rated as a
charity consistently given an F rating
from charity watch so not hate watch but
actual charity watch and that's why it's
important with Houston yet celebrity is
given to LGBTQ causes when they toss out
a sandwich but ninety-nine percent of it
goes to painting a rainbow flag on a bus
you should know where your money is
going there are a lot of colors that's
all we know the Houston food drive there
fifty new colors it's
gotta go down to Home Depot ain't gonna
paint itself well wasn't a sensor wasn't
she saying that with Linda sensor she
was saying that you know we're gonna go
if we're gonna go help these these
immigrant groups yeah we're not gonna
help everybody and it was like pretty
serious right you're for the pac-12
and exactly and this so this is why the
FBI has dropped the Southern Poverty Law
Center and then YouTube picked up where
they left off to give you an idea in
2011 I think they raised over seven
point five million dollars yeah
but they spent less than one point seven
of it on litigation kind of odd for an
organization that was founded on law
where's the money going so here's
something else YouTube is not only
consulting with them but they've invited
staff members from the Southern Poverty
Law Center to be a part of YouTube's
trusted flagger program that can only go
well yeah think about this they've been
invited saying we're gonna give you
access to these tools now they're
shutting a lot of people out now I will
say this we've had good contacts with
YouTube we've actually been informed
that we're probably not going to be
affected by a lot of these a lot of
these sort of hate speech guidelines on
YouTube obviously the D monetization has
been huge that's why the Mudd Club
support were incredibly grateful for it
but it is disconcerting when you see
okay Southern Poverty Law Center you're
you're inviting them in to use tools
while you're stripping other YouTube
partners of tools you're stripping their
videos of comments a thumbs up of the
ability to share it it goes into a ghost
roll on YouTube now that we don't know
how is it going to be rolled out we
don't know who's going to be affected so
hopefully we keep an eye on it but
you're something that knowing everything
we know now your YouTube your Google and
you're saying okay we need to clean it
we need to have some people are gonna
check us here we need to check our blind
spots and make sure that we're
considering all points of view and
determining what is and isn't hate
speech and you go with the organization
that classifies Ben Carson the same
breath as neo-nazis it certainly is a
proactive propaganda or is it just
ignorance question is does YouTube a
subsidiary of Google do they not have
access to Google and look whoever
controls the information controls what
people think this is important this is
really important exactly what happened
and you would talked about Nazis a
second ago this is what happened with
the Jews they started blaming the Jews
for the prob
that they were having they started
classifying these different groups
together and all the sudden you started
to get it into the psyche and people
started to make the connection our
problems are because of these groups of
people and I wish you hadn't used the
Nazi example they're calling us Nazis
don't call me a Nazi you're a Jew all
the time but that's why it's important
because it-it's the it's very easy to go
from where we're at even if YouTube is
totally gonna be nice to everybody it's
very easy strategy no matter what your
end goal it's a proven strategy if you
just if you just repeat it enough times
people go yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's hate speech where everyone's
going Ben Carson ben Carson gooble
gobble spam Carson hate speech and
you're not in your information age where
you're not actually listening to what
he's saying I'm using them because I'm
super benign exact course he's by the
way that hate map includes Christian
middle schools as hate groups yes I'm
not exaggerating go look at my map well
that's that that's the very next step
for Christians we're we're worried as
Christians because there's a lot of
beliefs that we hold that they would
label as hate speech right times right
and like guys that we don't hate anybody
that's the hole in it point amoral it
becomes a real [ __ ] to sacrifice
virgins people know process if you're
Episcopalians you do a mock sacrifice
man hate speech laws before we even get
to this that bothers me a lot yeah go
ahead so what about a Ben Shapiro I have
a real problem with legislating what
people think right and that's exactly
what HP is law Luke laws do and and I
heard about this I watched The West Wing
a lot in this there's an episode that
addresses this that really made the
point they were trying to do it and is
like wait a minute
murder is murder right like that the
person is still dead don't need
appointed them exactly you know what you
said I I don't I don't understand how
you can add on another ten I was like
well look if I go kill a mass murderer
does that knock off five like the Noland
penalties 20 but they were only gonna
give you 15 yeah it was a real jerk you
know yeah but if you kill a pregnant
lady they give you it to the bonus round
you get off scot-free law and order all
right Oh looks like murder I'll be doing
20 to life
sir he has a lisp add another ten yeah
oh and we're taking we're taking stuff
from the UN and UNESCO and those guys
over in Europe on Oh guys you got to
deal with racism it's the most racist
place on the planet yeah yeah and I
important because they hate crime laws
the hate speech law so what is a hate
crime
like I said murder doesn't need a
footnote so what you're really doing is
serving to legislate thought is you're
now serving to legislate listen if you
find a motive for a murder the reason
you're looking for a motive is because
you're looking to charge somebody with
murder the crime is what matters in this
case you're looking to use the murder to
try and charge someone with the motive
and that's what's so bastardize about it
and it's a game plan that works we have
to go to bench if you're here in a
second it's a game plan that works
because you see it here Oh hate speech
hate crimes therefore these people are
hateful and you intimidate organizations
into agreeing with you it's the same
thing that happens with with writing of
the hurricane you look at what's
happening with Harvey
well climate change all scientists agree
with me therefore that's what's
happening now less politicize it even
though scientists aren't necessarily
saying this could have been stopped by
anything Al Gore has proposed so we'll
talk about that more we'll come back
here with ben shapiro and then Dean Cain
[Music]
whole body with steven crowder and not
gay Jared as those warm summer nights
turn to cool fall evenings it's
important to not let the weather dictate
your healthy lifestyle that's why it's
paramount that you find an activity you
can practice indoors to stay fit and be
safe and today Darren a master purple
elf is going to teach chair the art of
Brazilian jiu-jitsu
a self-defense system of techniques that
teaches a smaller man how to defeat the
larger folk are you ready
definitely yeah sorry
safety first okay now today Darren's
going to be teaching us a rudimentary
technique with the rear naked choke now
it's important to note before we even
wrap your arms around your opponent's
neck you need to control his body proper
leverage that means using your legs
heizo we're supposed to apply any
pressure and apply any pressure but did
he tap it didn't teach you but sam wakes
up to get it okay today we'll be
learning a fundamental technique with
the rear naked choke now it's important
to note that before you even try to
perform the choke again I don't know how
this happens again let's just
homebody prick with steven crowder and
not a Jared
sponsored by mug Club
and Alfred episode 245 a game of Thrones
and a podcast so did you see that this
week Eugene in the episode yeah she was
genius yeah we'll be back with the
salvage 342 as we gave its own sander
podcast
[Music]
prophet Sulaiman code 16 good Japanese
it's even worse than I imagined private
sir yes sir the social justice disease
is plagued half the globe and it's
become a Leviathan greater than we could
have ever imagined
sir yes sir hey Jesus we could think it
we could write it out there's 30 day
food supply for prepare with credit calm
nine million dollars shipped free sir
that is true thank the Lord above for
prepare with kroehner calm 30 days seems
about the right amount of time we need
to ride this out it's good thing about
the social justice disease private
that's a very temporary phase sir yes
sir
you uh feeling okay private
sir yes sir you sure about that Sullivan
sir yes sir
you haven't been hanging out many slam
poetry nights or single organ
coffee-shop against my orders have you
sir no sir but I'm pretty sure systemic
racism is still inheritance is observed
in Jacques
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
prepare with Crowder dot-com or call
eight eight eight four one one five one
five three 30-day food supply kit $99
ship food they have pudding
[Music]
all right Ben Shapiro glad to have him
here of the Ben Shapiro show at Bailey
wire Kevin we have two hazmat suit to
clean up the mess here Ben how are you
today I am okay how are you doing
you're wearing the david copperfield
shirt to show off the guns exactly right
nothing up my sleeves unleash the Python
okay don't do that against that we
weren't going around Ben Daley why.com
people need to go listen to your show
the tumblers all right I guess before we
get into the personal stuff what is what
is the most important news story you
think of this week obviously outside of
the the the hurricane but the media
seems to be making a thing out of all
the things that aren't things if I can
articulate it so well but I think you'll
do it better well I mean I mean aside
from being 106 degrees in our student
having no air conditioning I think the
biggest story that affects me this week
it said is the they're a bunch of
they're a bunch of stories that I think
have been overlooked I think this story
about Comey apparently having a memo
ready to exonerate Hillary before the
evidence was even in which is just
breaking today that's a that's a fairly
big story that a lot of people aren't
covering yeah I think that President
Trump pushing for tax reform obviously
is a big story that hasn't gotten heavy
coverage I think you know some of the
some of the antiva coverage from Sunday
was stunted yeah even though that was a
huge story I agree with your with your
Game of Thrones with it with your Game
of Thrones movie I know one can take I
think that's right and the ante for
people you know running by and hit in
Game of Thrones characters in full run
yeah is I think a major issue that we
have to take on but that's actually it
actually is a huge issue especially yeah
I say affecting me personally like we
have been basically bit Berkeley you
know it's supposed to have us September
14th they still have not released
tickets there were two weeks out they
have not released a ticket yet I know he
had people down at the ticket office
today and the people at the ticket
office legitimately ran away from the
people like they got up and they just
ran away apparently like in jingle all
the way where they they hide behind the
toy shelves like oh no it's a stampede
of people it's a Disney film let's hide
oh it actually happened I wish that I
understood the reference but I've never
seen jingle all the way because no one
has ever seen jingle all the way
very sad life you and your you and your
t-shirts alright go ahead continue the
tax reform is not a bad thing just
horrible timing yeah exactly I mean I
don't know why President Trump decided
to do that this week there's also the
announcement that he might revoke daca
again I think right now Trump has a
winning news cycle for him just one
political point of view put aside the
human tragedy of all of this but sure it
were political analysts that means we
always look at sort of the political
fallout of this stuff and Trump has done
by pretty much any measure a decent job
he has done a good jacket I mean he's
the administration's did what they had
to do they coordinated with the people
on the ground there haven't been a lot
of complaints about federal malfeasance
he did the obligatory Here I am to show
that I care trip to Texas I hate that
kind of crap by the way because it seems
to me that the president has a TV and it
would be better if we used all the
resources on the ground to actually help
the people on the ground as opposed to
prepping the ground for Trump to arrive
I hated it when Obama did it I hate it
when Bush did it I don't like it when
Trump does it either but that's not on
Trump that's on the media that insists
that Trump do that sort of stuff I think
it's a rallying symbol for people in in
Texas you know listen there they can
maybe get a second win I can see how
it's valuable just for morale but it's
certainly not of the utmost importance
as the meet you know can you believe she
wore heels to get on the aircraft and
then left with sneakers yeah yeah I can
I'd do that at almost every flight does
that every week at synagogue every week
at synagogue right so like I understand
the changing of the shoes it's not that
big a deal
yeah but it just demonstrates that the
lengths to which the media will go to
try and turn a win into a loss for
president Trump it's not gonna work here
because there's no loss I mean he hasn't
done anything wrong here yeah again and
this is coming from somebody who is more
than willing to smack him when I think
he's doing something wrong and I don't
see any evidence that he's done anything
that really deserves criticism so much
in the aftermath of hurricane absolutely
and I think Governor Abbott deserves a
lot of credit this guy has been very
active in doing a really good job here
for all the political mudslinging people
have done a good and Moute listen
outside of media outside of New York LA
and DC most Americans have come together
to try and do the right thing all right
so we don't want to give this still we
still want to keep people entertained
again to give them some relief here tell
me we're asking how do I know Ben how do
we know each other
what's because we've known each other
for a long time so I figured let's let's
go to the time on here do you I don't
know if you remember
first met you do you remember who
introduced us I mean I assume was Andrew
Breitbart because you know I was in LA
and Andrew introduced everyone Mike
legitimately Andrew introduced everyone
to everyone
Strahm but the first time I remember
actually meeting you in person was I was
when you came to my condo because you
need a place to crash like get a flight
stopover you remember you you had to
come over and you had to like you needed
a place to store your stuff for a little
while the reason I remember this is
because you insisted on showing me your
Brazilian Jujitsu I remember that
because I remember where you lived I did
some research and it was right near the
Ralph Macchio apartment complex from
Karate Kid this is right and I walked
him like really I said how do you not
know this and you live here I was like
sounds like Owen Benjamin tell me you
should like like show you all the gas
stations okay I'm so pumped about the
Karate Kid I just remember you going out
there and charging on college and doing
the crane in the middle of the street I
was like what is going on but before we
met you were actually my first lawyer so
people don't andrew breitbart
introduced us this was in 2009 I think
and then you negotiate I was like Hasson
I don't know PJTV came and offered me a
contract you're you're a Jewish lawyer
I've heard you guys are the best can you
do this for me and so you negotiated a
contract with PJTV for me a lot people
don't realize you were the one who
handled my Fox contract as well yeah
read it over and even though I don't
necessarily an entertainment lawyer like
listen just make sure I'm not getting
screwed on these deals and you tweaked
the couple I mean a contract is a
contract so I knew enough to actually
read a contract and see where that where
the with potholes were I mean for you
the big issue that's getting your legal
background but the big issue was always
exclusivity what you were allowed to do
outside of Fox and what Fox forced you
to do inside a Fox the same thing with
PJ so yeah that stuff at least I knew
how to read for because I'd had the same
issues myself so it wasn't really that
what's the big thing people need to know
because the reason we're you know this
is a show for example I was at Fox
I was always pushing for to do something
like this and so we were been actually
protected me in a lot of ways where I
was always able to do what I wanted
outside of you know wherever else I was
working they didn't necessarily
like it consider cert it's I consider
breast I would have gotten gotten much
more airtime at the Foxwoods if I have
breath so so this is what happened I
don't know if you remember and I used to
do your show for people who don't know
yet a show up in Orlando on the weekends
and I used to do this show in Orlando
and we were the first so among the first
contributors ever it was before was
Breitbart it was big Hollywood for
people who don't know there was you I
came in just because uh Andrew long
story anyways it was you Adam Baldwin I
know myself John Nolte there were only a
handful who contributed from the
beginning and I don't know does this
does this mean anything to you for
people out there this is this is not Ben
has does not have any kind of talking
points here just Crowder's three-ring
circus ring a bell to you know this is
before long this is the for ladder with
garden was ever a thing you're like well
listen I can see that you know you're a
popular contributor at big Hollywood and
I remember sitting there he's like and I
think like a good site would be
Crowder's three-ring store that would be
the umbrella site for where you do your
own content and I want equity and by the
way if I had gotten equity right now I'd
be a much wealthier man look at you with
your nice studio and the neon and back
and the Conan the Barbarian I don't sign
in the whole deal I don't have the silk
shirts though I don't have the silk
trips come on yes in Orlando you had
your show primetime not show he had your
book primetime propaganda and this is
before you really had you were alright
you came to the body you came in the
book party for that and then you took
the photos and and this is another one
of our bad memories we have a but Steve
and I have a bunch of like great
memories and bad memories you I'll wrap
together so one of our bad memories is
that you and Jordan did the photos for
that and then that was the only photo I
had with Andrew Breitbart and it has
gone forever I have no no but it's one
of those weird things you know like I'm
sure that you and I probably have no
photos together even though we've seen
each other a bunch of times and run your
show together in my show together
yeah beside from split screens then like
you know when you're friends with
somebody how often do you actually say
you know let's snap a photo together
especially two guys yeah right like that
just doesn't happen like my wife has
pictures of all her friends right I'm
not sure I've ever taken a picture with
my father like once you know I think
that's something you got it's not a dude
thing really unless you're embarrassing
someone then you take the picture when
you really embarrass them and then the
only picture you have is like Oh
my balls on my friends face that's not
one for the scrapbook so I we didn't
well you and I need neither of us wanted
that picture out there no no so here's
what takes me to the next thing this is
this is all true there's a long and
short history and then it gets to a cold
felt we'll talk about that but so I did
go over to Ben's place I remember
because he actually submitted me there
was for a radio gig and he may or may
not remember this but this is actually
where I don't know oh he said submit and
I was thinking like yeah yeah he he
recommended me he grappled and I bungled
it it was so bad he this little sound
system in his room and this is after I
remember showing him jujitsu and I did a
guillotine choke and he was like my
hernia I was like well you have to tell
me you have a hernia I didn't know I
wouldn't choke you if I knew you had a
hernia I did this in editors remember it
was it was one of those it was a radio
gig like a news it was like and this is
the news this morning this happened it
couldn't be less me and you you risk
your reputation and recommended me and I
knew as soon as was and I couldn't even
look you in the Iowa it was so bad I
don't remember the fallout but it's been
years since you were on that radio
station so yeah man I'm so I'm so I feel
so bad that I disappointed Ben he put me
up for that and I just remember it was
bought it was scripted you had to read
the entire script and they're like we
don't want any input we want no input
and then all it was was I was reading a
script like input input input like a
bank will give you a call kid and they
hung out and I had to walk out of the
room and you're like so how did it go
and I said what about to choke in you
surely I think that'll be more pleasant
lost that roll in there will be blood
yes yes yes if I ruin your radio show so
um and then we now then we didn't we've
weren't a lot of people who came into
this later you and I didn't interact as
much for a while and I've talked about
on this show but I think you know you
were at Breitbart at this point and they
kind of did this someone there did kind
of a hit piece on when I left Fox saying
oh he was fired for not being funny and
I remember um there was no spy line in
the article and no source and all I knew
was the producer I spoke with it Fox
were like no none of us ever said this
and so for a while even you know I was
leery of
anyone who was working there and you
were still there for a little bit so I
don't know Frank April who don't know we
kind of explained that that that time
period because you had your own stuff
going on yeah I mean so this was late
2013 and Breitbart had come into
conflict with a bunch of people who had
worked with the came to conflict with
you came into conflict Danny lash there
are a lot of people who really
disassociated sort of from anyone
working with Breitbart for some reasons
that I think I'm probably not bad
reasons and by late 2013 I had already
started my own project on the side I was
already launching truth revolt which was
sort of the precursor site almost for
daily wire with the David Horowitz
freedom Center and so I was basically
out of the editorial chain by the time
that article was written I had that
article the truth roll launched like
October 7th 2013 I think that article
you sent me the link today I think the
article was like a couple of weeks after
that so I was already sort of out of the
loop as far as editorial because I was
running my own site at that point and
then by January 2014 I was completely
out of the editorial with the Breitbart
altogether I was writing with one piece
a day for them right but I wasn't
intimately involved in editorial at all
but yeah I mean yeah the usually more is
a figure at that point because you you
people at this point you're developing
reputation you were getting more of a
public you know this I guess you're
getting more public airplay and so like
you said you were doing one piece a day
but I was going well he's their main guy
and there's this article and I know that
I know at least portions of it were
flat-out untrue and so there was this
miscommunication for a long time I want
to say at least a year Ben and I we
weren't enemies ever but we just didn't
talk because it wasn't a risk I wanted
to take right exactly and then and then
I can't remember what prompted us to
start texting each other again it must
have been after I left Breitbart I'll
bet it was probably it was it was before
it was yeah you had been on the show and
I remember I remember this is kind of
timeline where I start coming in yeah
you started coming in yeah and I was
like I remember yeah I was like yeah
Ben's a really smart guy just I was I
just be careful with him don't don't let
him on the inside track here at all
because I don't necessarily know because
again I didn't know I just knew this
stuff happened at Breitbart Andrew and I
were friends you and Andrew were friends
and the whole thing changed and all of
Andrews closest friends was like it was
just a bunch of shrapnel and no one knew
up from down that's right yeah Andrew
was the glue that held the entire thing
together and then when he died and the
site changed in a variety of ways that
definitely fractured a lot of relations
for sure and then you texted me out of
the blue and you start asking about the
article and I didn't remember the
article yeah and we had a long text
conversation and finally I was like well
I don't really remember that but I'm
sorry that happened
and you know obviously that's not what I
think of you since you know I've been
pushing your stuff on our sites for
years yeah so you know on truth revolt
and daily wire
I mean daily wire we post your your
videos virtually all the time yeah and
even though you're an even though your
tumblr sucks we promote you all the time
and even before that you know with the
primetime propaganda as a book it was
just I just thought it was a great book
I still recommend people go read it
because a lot of people probably haven't
read it because that was before you
became immensely popular so they
probably read some of your newest stuff
right but that I would put amongst some
of the most important pieces of anything
that you've written yeah I appreciate it
yeah that was that was the book party he
came to us for primetime propaganda
which was sort of the underground
Hollywood debunking all of their
mythology about not being political book
yeah and by the way thank you for the
reference to the tumblr it is just
glorious
but if you like asbestos it's a thriller
make fun of yours exactly well I mean
the nice thing is that you'll die in
luxury of your cancer holding this in
your withered hand obviously we
recommend your crappy mug as well and we
and we put your stuff on our shows too
so here's Coptic relationship I think
but it's yeah we had to get beyond the
poisonous the poisonous time way that's
the whole thing I think it's important
less than just as far as people out
there there can just again we never Ben
and I were never on the outs like Jared
knows actually just be careful because I
don't really I don't know what's
happening and I was with that with
everyone who was from the whole kind of
Breitbart fallout because unlike you
know there were only handful of people
who were invited directly to Andrews
funeral and Emer I wasn't able to make
it funny funny enough because I was
actually shooting a pilot for an MMA
show for fuel TV which then got bought
by the UFC but they scrapped this at
like fuel TV said we will never do MMA
it'll be cars and extreme sports and I
got I remember when this happened and I
didn't make it to the funeral but Adam
Baldwin saying you know what if you
really if you're it's down to you and
one guy and it's this screen test Andrew
would have wanted you to do it and I was
the only person I think he was invited
there who never really worked for Andrew
I wrote consistently I constantly can we
were just friends you know
just a supporter it was a really weird
time but people out there kind of
hearing that you know it just it just
goes to show you just talk you know see
you see with families in this case it
wasn't so severe but if we just talked
about it a lot of this would have been
cleared up more calling coke and
[Laughter]
everything but there is there's a Jewish
concept beyond making money that is
excellent and that concept is that you
are you are supposed to always try and
attribute the best possible motives to
people until you're proved wrong yes I
think that holds on on both sides of
this particular one and then the very
next verse has attribute the best
possible motives because it's immensely
profitable all right and so this is what
Lannister people are saying about your
story it's been back to 2009 he was my
first lawyer because it was the only
lawyer that I knew he was very smart we
kind of didn't talk for a while and now
he's back here and I think he's one of
the smartest minds out that we go see
Ben let's see it last time
let's see them let's see the tumblr yeah
let's see that tumblr looks great we're
still we're ahead of you in the
programming ability so we can see things
that you can't now it is the great mug
war of our time we'll see what happens
with it but Ben Shapiro bench beer show
at Daily wire you can listen for free on
iTunes and of course subscribe to there
to get the video stuff so you can see
his wonderful appointment as his Simon
Cowell t-shirts Ben thank you very much
sir here's to hopefully many more years
yeah thanks a lot o bestest
[Music]
right now
[Music]
[Music]
sweet Mary and Joseph Robert Sullivan
get you the fallout shelter I always do
those ragheads will make it to our Shore
Sullivan sir yes sir thank the Lord
above we prepared we prepare with Crider
calm $99 ship free for a 30 day
emergency food supply kit sir yes sir
every need reasonably priced via full
meals freeze-dried free soup and pudding
sir just add heat and water that's right
private just add heat and where's all
the water private so then do you mean to
tell me that we fought with the most
basic giving accessory in exchange for
caffeinated sugary soda pop I thought we
need our energy serve the terrorists
[Music]
prepare with Crowder dot-com for call
eight eight eight four one one five one
five three 30-day food supply kit $99
ship they have pudding
[Music]
[Music]
all right glad ever next case look at
all the tweets off sunlight the lines
are lighting up ending up if we actually
have a on line with ladies no with
ladies who what's funny is deemed well
at real Dean Cain mister mister Dean
Cain and you're scheduled this time good
to have you on absolutely ladies who
love you I mean like there is this whole
fan group and I don't even think they're
necessarily politically conservative so
this showing not be up their alley but
they'll get direct messages like Dean's
on you need to let us know that we can
make sure to notify our fan club members
like they what's the relationship like
with people like that and it's my mom
and my sister pretty simple which is odd
because I get a purely sexual very
quickly so there's people that are fans
like that for less amande I'm very happy
for that you know doing these Comic Cons
and things like that that I'll do
sometimes around the country around the
world you know people will say very nice
things and you know you play a superhero
for you know for a number of years and
sometimes an impressionable youth and
and they'll hang on to you forever
I'm okay well it surprises me though
because you're very outspoken
politically I mean we've always talked
about this nukkie dude he doesn't hold
back at all which is nothing cuz I when
I see you on the Today Show and they're
playing is that rude or not rude and
it's softball like double dipping I'm
like do you realize what this guy like
like you would hate what he stands for
when he said just nice good as in to
lose he's already Dean Cain I mean yeah
I guess they just wouldn't if they
actually got it to a real discussion
with me about the politics of it yeah on
the face of it they'd be so upset oh how
could you possibly say this that or the
other thing then you talk to five
minutes think oh that makes sense that's
interesting okay I could see where
you're coming from
yeah gorgeous I hate you Nazi yes Tommy
that's Twitter I get that on Twitter all
the time like do you do you know what a
weak wooden Nazi is like you really
understand what a Nazi as you call yeah
yeah yeah whatever white supremacist
who's been with the name Tanaka yes so
exactly yeah you probably have a zero
somewhere in your lineage you okay so
you've been doing the Today Show I won't
you know but hopefully if people want to
see you know Dean Cain and they're more
tweet at real Dean Cain
to Today Show and see him doing it fun
phrasing yeah yeah sorry no see him
doing it see doing the show I would love
to see you hosting a show only to get if
only to get one of the good guys in
there but you were talking about this
right before the break and I said haha
say before air right during the break
you said you been traveling a lot
go ahead this is the thing that blew me
away I've been all over the this this
summer I've been all over the world
so I was down in Australia I was in
Sydney I was in Perth I was in Brisbane
Gold Coast Byron Bay back over to Europe
London two or three times back to Spain
I cannot tell you why I can tell you
it's probably in the dozens the numbers
of people who come to me and go love you
in louder with Crowder you're across the
globe they're like oh we watch it so
funny it's so good so smart and I'm like
you live in Perth Western Australia and
they're like absolutely in Perth itself
20 people
yes quietly it's like love you out loud
with Browder get like can you say you
know the Superman oh my god I get like
you know louder with crowded mug I'm
like what right that's correct you know
else is crazy ever the sound guy didn't
get my I think we fix it Jordan Peterson
wishes we accidentally double-booked the
both you don't worry about it
Jordan can wait we got Superman yes he's
a bright guy if you have been following
Jordan Peterson though to the left
absolutely despises him because he I
think it's a big thing with you is you
you disarm a lot of them now I know
listen you're a nice guy and I
appreciate the compliment and I I'm
always surprised when people abroad
that's something new there are some more
conservatives across the world they just
didn't really know they were
conservative they thought Republican no
one's as right-wing as the United States
then when they kind of started learning
some ideas now with new media and
YouTube exploding open yeah they're open
they're going oh London I mean 150
people it was just it was I was like I
was like their camera yeah is crowded I
know what you're have you seen my recent
Hallmark Christmas film that's nothing
to debts nothing to shake a stick at
door right they don't care
yeah although the one with the kids were
you Internet when you when you adopted
the kids that was great that was great
it was there I'm prouder better I keep
hallmark on a loop when it's around
Christmas time let me ask you this we
were talking about the the Houston
Charlie Hebdo magazine cover Politico
listen I I don't think that you and I
are in the business of being offended
but here's one thing that I do think
when you look at Hebdo and it paints
Houston as Nazis and you see le the Tea
Party or don't tread on me this other
the political thing they tweet out
you're a nice guy but do you see in the
entertainment industry in LA and in New
York you're doing the Today Show you
know if the name names
the contempt for everyone outside of the
coast because I think that's what's
happening with new media some of the
people are offended
it just shows other contempt for people
in Middle America and their views I do
see a lot of that I see that when I say
oh I support this that or the other
thing I support the president Trump or
this policy that he has I don't support
every policy the president Trump has no
I don't support every policy I have I
say this all the time you know there's
things you think about you're like oh
that was stupid that's not so great so I
thought about this when I first said it
they're like what did you I'm like well
let's think about let's talk about this
that the thing you start talking and
then you find you know you have some
common ground but it's like getting past
that first hurdle is like literally
taking a tennis racket it's smacking him
in the face yeah there's the shock on
the face so I look look look look for me
and I said this on the Today Show
the thing about Houston is so amazing is
the way people are coming together and
all that's the story to me look what
they're doing right first of all the
government's doing a heck of a job
Governor Abbott said they've done it you
know it's an A+ job yeah they're working
their tails off it's the most expensive
situation Houston's like what is it two
inches above sea level anyway I mean
it's it's a tough place it floods a lot
yeah and it's horrible and it's and what
but what people are doing and the way
they're coming together and there you
know Texans you guys are in Texas
Texans are unbelievable and in a crisis
you want some Texas I think that right
now it's all a contempt for middle
America I think you seized ignorant to
know she sends a pretty diverse city in
Texas as a whole is not actually went
surprise people one year I don't know if
it was Oh for or if it was oh wait I
think it was Oh for someone can correct
me on this because I don't want to make
this claim but someone can show me there
was one year where it surprised me
Austin went red and Houston went blue
and I don't think a lot of people
realize that that Houston is actually
surprisingly metropolitan and
surprisingly mixed and and not super
conservative you think joel osteen you
think megachurches so they're really
mocking a lot of their own cultural
diversity there's a lot more cultural
diversity in Texas and people think it's
not just a bunch of rednecks with with
Confederate flags running around here no
I'm sorry you see a lone star flag yes
obviously a lot of Confederate flags I
was like a Confederate flag in Texas I'm
like no I wouldn't see that it's pretty
rare but I mean that was a horribly
inaccurate
cartoon now that doesn't make me angry I
just go that's just stupid yeah it's
stupid it's just something to say it's
not funny you're making a point that
isn't really a point yeah and it's not
risky at all to me what really bothers
me is just the laziness of the comedy
hey guys aren't they Nazis okay all
right what else do you got there's no
risk there and I think actually Charlie
Hebdo someone came out there and
apologize about the Mohammed thing right
off the bat they were kind of they were
a little bit insolent saying no we're
not gonna apologize and then later on I
can't remember what it is that they did
but someone that walked it back I'm
going really I mean it so that's think
they should do is apologize for Mohammed
cartoon yeah I know sorry
well you know and here's what's crazy
just drawing Mohammed even in a
flattering way it's considered far more
offensive to Muslims than it is even to
Texans to draw them drowning in a flood
in a mocking way that's not a problem is
you don't get the problem with the
drawing Mohammed thing is you don't get
to pick the rules by which I play I can
draw whatever I want it doesn't matter
what your religion says and they
shouldn't apologize for the hurricane
Harvie drawings either no they shouldn't
apologize it's just lazy
yeah this is lazy and stupid I look at
him not even worth my time I mean if you
didn't ask me specifically right now I
wouldn't comment that's just stupid well
I just what's one of the test friends
along with apparently it was it Macomb
County what county is that we're now or
we only shoot black people oh yeah
Macomb is in Detroit where I was oh
that's right that's right in Georgia you
you saw this video I were we haven't
even talked about it this show but I
will say I haven't seen the video after
I saw the headline anyone who doesn't
know that this is clearly sarcasm is
willfully lying or functionally [ __ ]
the lady says well I'm just really
nervous because I've I've been pulled
over in the cop ghost well haven't you
heard
we only shoot black people in this
county have you seen the videos all we
do is kill black people out here it
shouldn't joke like that because I'm
Peter it looks really bad damning some
might say yeah paper I read the
transcript before I watched it video I
was like oh my god oh it's the opposite
day you know he was Carly's dad joke
yeah yeah really is yours imagine the
written word yes it's a dad joke over
which you lose your job yes
unfortunately most dad jokes should be
alright can you give me this is true I
know you'd only point at you Jerry
alright Today Show are you do you know
what's gonna happen there you're on
there all the time
does anyone come people do people here
no are you are you gonna be a permanent
fixture there well megyn kelly is coming
in to have the nine o'clock hour soon so
we'll see what happens all right yeah
you know that's not the normal Malibu
background yes are you planning on going
down to Texas at all or I know obviously
a lot of times people I mean you could
actually lift things and help people as
opposed and I would love to be there and
do that because in that situation I
would be nails I would love to do it
love to be able to help I don't have I'm
working so I don't have time to get down
there now there was a some time I was
supposed to go down and I have to do a
bunch of trips abroad I've donated some
money already and I've certainly talked
about it quite a bit but I'm not much I
can't get down there no you use your
luck see the fact this though I love to
see like this someone was driving in
today and they filmed a line of about I
don't know 700 trucks towing a little
flatbed boats yeah I was like you guys
are all people trying to get in to help
yeah and that's Texas and that's what
that's America and that's what I love
and I just makes me jump up and down I
go yes and I feel like that's that's how
most people are taking this right now
most people obviously there's there's
this unity outside of the DC New York LA
unholy alliance where there did you know
Chris Cuomo tried to do the climb
change thing with Kelly and Conway and
she just I mean she practically pegged
him on TV it was so embarrassing she's
like okay you play amateur climatologist
we talked about this earlier today by
the way if you're in New York if you see
Chris Cuomo I know you're polite but
just quote me directly and tell him that
I think he's everything that's wrong
with journalism and television
can I get in a wrestling match with him
into only if there's oil involved or gel
one or the other or all of the above all
right we'll listen I keep her supposed
to people who haven't been watching The
Today Show I would love to see deeply
wouldn't you I'd love to see him there
get in there and mix some things up and
hopefully hopefully they let you do a
little more than BuzzFeed rude or or not
rude maybe the last seven or eight
o'clock hours yeah okay there you go and
next time you should write in some
questions like hey listen let me give
you some of these flashcards for for
rude or not ruin it's like drawing
Mohammed and just see watch everyone's
face melt you know my answer would be
not rude don't they have a drawing right
in there and then then they go and yeah
well we'll talk Dean we'll talk about we
come back the execution of Dean Cain yes
all right
at real Dean Cain's we Lauren following
him a great friend of the show do a lot
of good work and let Today Show
[Music]
and now for episode 645 but the Game of
Thrones fair the podcast
okay this afford to stay on topic did
you see ever so last week I gave it rose
and would you find most fascinating
about that what I thought that Jon Snow
was doing a lot with the Tai Chi I used
to get to talk about losing parts
I just thought some of the narratives
that tied together we're interests you G
no one cares about that crap people do a
podcast you're about to bunch of boys on
the show stay tuned for episode 694 as a
game of Thrones there the podcast where
Yugi will be replaced with an adult film
actress
[Music]
[Music]
and close my eyes I open it and there
you are glad to have you that was deemed
King no drowning dance this week no that
would be horrible insensitive would be
very it would be in poor taste or taste
somebody say almost in poor taste to say
that it would be in poor taste it's
almost like we're drawing attention to
the fact that it would be in poor taste
said your hate milder at knock a jerk
tweet him not me
love Dean Cain love bench pure I know
it's been a little more personal tonight
but again what the news week has been
dominated by obviously Harvey and it's
it's terrible sometimes it's hard to get
your head around and people feel
helpless like there's not a whole lot
they can do like I said you know we're
given $30 for every mug Club Center for
the next two weeks and prepare with
Crider calm they're mashed it so that's
kind of what we can do but we've noticed
a lot of people to have shut off news
this week because at a certain point you
do what you can and then you have to
move on and we just didn't want to
wallow in it I know everyone is is hyper
politicizing it and I know we have to
address it and so it's hypocritical
because we're technically politicizing
it by addressing Chris Cuomo Pluto I get
it it's not lost on me but hey listen
this is a good time this this show is a
relief for a lot of you it's like going
to a movie and a stressful time in your
life that's something that I've done
we're not here to hammer you over the
head with red meat lines and do an ad
that gets a three second play on
Facebook about how bad barack obama is
who also isn't president anymore
so if we're not entertaining you we're
not doing our job that's something we
can contribute we did our best but
knocking Jared you had a good point
actually earlier today I just a thought
and this week you see so many people
trying to help hold that thought for
people who are not mug Club members who
he scalded his tongue so he's been
talking about Mushmouth for a week they
I just realized they probably just
thought well knocking Jared got really
not okay go ahead so I just thinking
about it's a lot and there's so many
people who want to help and I think
sometimes this hurricane harvester
tuition has provided a perfect parallel
and that they want to help and they help
in all the wrong ways they help in the
ways that make them feel good about
themselves and help in the ways I make
them feel like they're being helpful
without at not actually ever being
helpful there's parallels there with
that liberalism worthy they think
they're helping the black community
think of helping the the LGBT community
by and doing this or that or supporting
these causes with those calls
and they're really causing more harm
than good in the long term you know the
people who not everyone means harm I'd
support those things I think about
people who get sucked in to really think
they are doing some good in the world
right but I think we got to be smart in
the way we do these things it's if you
really care about these communities
learn how to really best help them
because yeah feeling like help limb is
not the same thing no exactly it's not
the same thing well it was a celebrity I
forgot forgot her name who gave a bunch
of money to the local LGBTQ Center
there's one only wanted to help black
only yeah which I'm sure that's well
that's what we call a Southern Poverty
Law Center so there were someone who
gave it just to the LGBTQ Center then I
actually had our our researcher reg I
said hey can we look into how much good
these because we do never want to attack
someone is doing good even if we
disagree with her it's can we look into
how much of their funding this LGBTQ
Resource and Houston gives to the
community how much they would be and he
said listen we look into their tax
returns as a non-profit it's hard
because I've never done any relief stuff
so we'd have to know after this year to
then see if they've even contributed
anything it's so I wouldn't want to
comment on this either way and I
appreciate that our researcher one of
our producers helped us with that but on
the flip side the person who gave to
this LGBTQ charity right now they're so
in a 1-1 track mindset as far as the
only way I can help is through this
LGBTQ political activism I'm gonna give
it to them listen it doesn't matter what
these people need food particularly
non-perishable food if they're somewhere
where unless you have diesel you're not
getting to them okay they need food
maybe someone want them they need yeah
they need some can openers they need
they need resources they need financial
funding for people who are going on
those specialized skills so electricians
plumbers they don't need a bunch of
volunteers going there with soup ladles
it was it remember hurricane between uh
people running into each other like
inbred mice they didn't know what they
were doing they weren't organized they
said listen we don't need more
volunteers we need money but four people
know they're doing this politically hurt
yes those volunteers are gonna get hurt
so you need to look into what it is that
they need but people who don't say you
know I'm just gonna give it because it
eases my guilt to give it to the LGBTQA
AIP number two group they can't even get
beyond the idea that you know what
listen yeah there are LGBTQ people in
Houston who are who are suffering yeah
there are probably black lives matter
who are suffering but there are also
some white people some of whom may be
even be conservative and guess what some
of whom may even be conservative and
maybe under the poverty line and may be
single moms and maybe they need help too
so what you need to do is look and see
how do they need help right now it's
namely resources meaning financial
resources and places they need homes
they need space that's really what they
need at this point not so much the
volunteer but if you can only volunteer
then do it and that's another thing as a
biblical principle as Christians and
we've talked about this and it's very
clearly outlined I had someone at church
one time we did a sermon he said I think
that a millionaire only thinks about his
next million and where it's coming from
right after that i sweared he says a
Greenfield Park Baptist he passed the
Hat for his missions work oh all of a
sudden those millionaires come in handy
now some people are greedy millionaires
absolutely as a matter of here's here's
a litmus test if you had a million
dollars right now what would you do with
it what would you take a million dollars
or now what would you do with it tweet
me des Crowder when you have these
self-righteous people who say no I don't
think I'd want it good you don't deserve
that money if you say well how many cars
do you need you don't deserve that
million dollars because guess what
you're just thinking about what you can
do for yourself but I don't want to
vilify the wealthy I love that Miley
Cyrus was able to get five hundred
thousand dollars I think it's great the
Kevin Hart was able to give twenty five
thousand dollars these cherries I would
love to be able to sign over a million
dollar check there's nothing wrong with
that you can do a lot of good if someone
were to hand you a million dollars right
now and you would think about what car
you buy I don't want you having a
million dollars if so everybody give you
a million dollars now you think hey what
third lake house could I get I don't
want you Bernie Sanders to have a
million dollars but I do want the people
who say you know it with another million
dollars I bet you I could feed a lot of
people you know what with another
million dollars I bet you that I could
probably house some of these animals and
hopefully reunite them with their owners
know what with another million dollars I
bet you I could at least help maybe turn
on some electricity for some of these
folks money just amplifies character
money is amoral
you can take money you can use it to go
buy a cocaine or you can take money and
you can use it to get somebody off
cocaine just like a gun you can use it
to rape somebody you can use it to stop
a rape and so the left in vilifying the
wealthy and you vilify the people who
you need most in these times any if you
get in a one
tragg mind we're the only way you can
help it's gotta be the oppression
Olympics today it's the LGBTQ it's but
mostly the tea today so we're gonna side
with them against the LG and the and the
Q you get to a point where you have no
semblance of reality and you don't know
how to best help people if you keep
vilifying that this is something that is
really important to me I know when
people say well you know what I'm uh I'm
socially more conservative but you know
none moral issues I'm more liberal on
financial issues I'm liberal it's not a
moral issue theft isn't a moral issue
when you're talking about taxes and
redistribution now money is almost
always a moral issue and at the very
least it amplifies the moral issue and
if you spend as the left does as Bernie
Sanders us and shank right shank right
now Jake we going out and he said you
know not a single dime goes to help help
any of these oil refineries well guess
what now the single mom in Dallas
[ __ ] can't get gas because there's a
shortage you want to make that worse you
and your stupid self-righteous your
piety you're hurting the people you
claim you who do you think is hurt most
by you saying I don't I don't want I
want to punish these oil companies I
want to tax them yeah you think Elon
Musk is hurt or do you think maybe it's
the single black mom who you're
pandering to for votes the next election
cycle who has to pay for ninety five a
gallon and that's the problem when you
don't live in reality you have no
semblance of a moral backbone what do
you do you blame you blame inanimate
objects I'm gonna blame the gun I'm
gonna blame the money right now I want
rich people
I want rich people to help and I want to
be a rich person and the success of this
show not only will be measured by how
much we entertaining you but how many
rich people we make because of this show
people who work with see our TV and mug
Club that's a huge measurement of
success because I know that I want
people in this room to go out and I want
money in their hand when a disaster like
this strikes because they rallied
together in said how can we help these
people and within a matter of days we
got an entire website up with the
bandwidth necessary to make sure that we
are helping those in need I would love
to see them with more
don't just look at somebody with money
like shank or Bernie Sanders and
ironically judge them remember they're
not supposed to be prejudiced but anyone
who has a wallet fatter than yours
you're supposed to try and take what he
has I want to see good people I want to
see Dean Cain on The Today Show for the
same reason that I want to see the
people who I know would do tremendous
good with money to be billionaires
because guess what if you vilify
everybody who's wealthy if you vilify
the mere idea of wealth the only people
who will become wealthy are those who
don't care about being vilified the only
people who will be wealthy are the
villains so shut up with your
self-righteousness
find out what people need and get to
work and help
[Music]